c'est non non mais la menace a marre
connais tu vas tu mais attendez ça va on
va commencer parce que je voulais
quelque chose parce que si dieu des
mines et ça m'a conduit à vous la péter
parce que c'est la coutume japonais
réfléchissait protéger les courbettes
quand vous faites comme ça d'accord mais
là ça va ça va oui ça va quoi ni suivant
comment tu vois pas comment tu vas mais
c'est vrai qu'on y voit comment ils
n'ont connu tu vas connectez vous rené
tu connais qui va ça va d'accord ça va
être
connais tu vas ok mais ça m'a connu tu
veux c'est vrai quoi coco en déplorant
la patagonie gaga défendue samedi me dit
à dick a interviewé des militants est la
suivante ont laissé tout différent
vicieusement nous avions prévenu pierre
desproges que son visiteur était un faux
journaliste japonais mais kôji lui ne
savait pas que des proches savaient si
bien que c'est lui notre camp japonais
qui veut se faire piéger
chacun son tour bonjour bien oui
avez vous eu une attirance particulière
pour le japon est extrême au lion je
peux répondre franchement je réponde non
pas japonais non je parle pas parlé je
veux je crois pas que j'ai des
attirances particulière pour le japon
je n'aime pas tellement non c'est pas
raciste mais j'aime mieux les blancs
pauvres que j'y serai l'équipe et ses
effets ça regardez ça m'est égal je
pense
avez-vous des japonais
chez vous oui exemple tout à l'heure oui
d'autre part appelé japonais oui j'ai je
peux me lever langue quoi j'ai juste
derrière le piano tout fait couper le
dire hier le preneur de sons la hausse à
90 ou de suite là ça c'est ça oui
si le départ c'était japonais mais ici à
mornant se souvient de kyoto ça c'est
pas vous aimez il tourne plus là
monsieur tout ça c'est ça tourne pas là
mais si mais si ça avant il y avait le
fuji yama j'ai enlevé mes bonnes soeurs
que plus joli que le et ça c'est le
papier glacé mais ça devient cet âge et
le nom mais au japon nous sommes tous
interdépendants
mais il ya eu des missionnaires au japon
catholique c'est pour cela vous avez
bouffé me semble un peu bizarre oui ces
messieurs n'ont pas ce que dit d'avant
il y avait le fuji yama et j'ai mis la
belle soeur parce qu'elle est plus
rigolo will hélas hélas non non non la
langue et les fans chinois je connais
c'est vrai ça voilà si si ça vient ça
c'est japonais c'est du bois de ces du
tech
d'autres s'étonnent ce sont des animaux
sauvages mènera s'est cassé mais c'est
la dix septième siècle avant à oui si je
connais c'est des animaux qui se fait
mais qu'est ce qui fait l'amour voilà
mais sont mariés à ces pavés bouton
sport
bon y'a pas l'autre le ch a maintenant
la question de confiance
que pensez-vous de la philosophie la
philosophie c'est finalement le
philosophie zen n'est pas vraiment une
philosophie japonaise est en fait elle
était importée de l'inde
17e siècle c'est une confusion en europe
entre par les gens ils s'imaginent que
le zen est une philosophie née en
extrême orient de tout en or ce n'est
japonais depuis trois siècles
alors bon bien sûr c'est déjà influencé
les mentalités je pense qu'on peut dire
mon amour que les circonstances dans la
vie où l'homme si certains se fait soit
ils en arrivent à des contingences et
kanak semble tout relativité notamment
sur le deuxième je suis vous êtes un
argument liste connaissait peu et moi
prenons ya pas d'humour japonais même si
elles signent un niveau japonais
absolument qu'il y en a je sais qu'il ya
eu il ya une histoire à ce propos et au
fox moi je trouve que c'est pas de
l'humour
enfin sincérité quelle est votre
définition de rumeurs français et de
donner un exemple
l'humeur français mais c'est sa
définition de l'humeur ya pas de
définition de de l'humour c'est c'est un
état d'esprit
je sais pas si vous pouvez piger ça vous
parce que monsieur monsieur se passe il
ya le même forme d'humour en extrême
orient russe surtout au japon qu'en
france il ya une chose dont le qui est
arrivé au japon qui a été fait par un
japonais s'est elle ça ressemble à de
l'humour japonais mais en fait c'était à
mon avis et d'humour française c'est
quand le votre empereur hirohito il
s'appelle ils vivent encore très vivant
et hiro hito il a reçu jackie kennedy
c'est la femme de jack kennedy
il l'a reçue il le propose et du café il
lui a dit tu veux du kawasaki parce
qu'il ne plaisait qui voit l'arrivée du
kawasaki en c'est marrant mais c'est pas
moi je trouve ça nous donne un faut-il
être un bon joker est au bord de gan moi
ce que je suis vigueur oui c'est chez
moi me dire m'insulter cadre c'est une
insulte
regardez kôji c'est une injure de dire
aux gens qu'ils sont vulgaires et
commence à trembler kôji vous pensez que
je suis vu lien
en janvier ça ça part vite que vous
dites c'est un ça signifie et qui est
dans lol oui la vulgarité c'est la
bassesse c'est tout ce qui est bas et
tout ce qui est bas vu qu arrêter ça
c'est la bassesse et la bassesse oui
c'est ce qui vous le dire c'est ce qui
est commun le mot vulgaire vient du
latin vulgus qui veut dire comme un bon
donc une certaine façon de dire bonjour
peuvent être vulgaire midi d'ossau
connaissait qui menace terroriste
vulgaire ça va pas la tête avec maurice
guerre abb aspect peu père bein je suis
pour lille oui lille rire à pour faire
rire un secret buffet rires oui j'imite
des bruits d'animaux par exemple ça fait
beaucoup
j'imite j'ai fait des imitations des
animaux avant le crid si c'est possible
ça fait rire je peux vous faire le cri
du cochon
oui le prix du cochon ça c'est fragile
qu'elle a le cri du cochon sa maison
ouais c'est amusant c'est la vache mais
c'est la vache à lait d'un an
kawasaki moscou ou à ski
vous gagnez pas le fonction publique
pour soi dont j'attends je fais mon beau
frère si je peux éviter imiter mon beau
frère
bonjour pierrot ça va le seul but du
rire jaune tout cas pas avant si vous
connaissez pas vous faire ces moments
avant très bien à travers votre humeur
humour
you may use sirugue les tubes eu lieu à
trèbes et votre rigueur vous voulez vous
faire passer un message et le kent un
message à travers l'humour c'est
difficile tout le monde et ça je pense
qu'on peut dire que s'il est pour les en
amont avec des si les hommes tous les
hommes du monde voulait vécu de ces
données
genou par exemple je pars on pourrait
faire un enchaînement centrait pour
l'humanité entière
nous avons demandé à chacune des
personnalités que nous avons honte aviv
et de la comté yonnais histoire dans lol
qui illustre bien mieux la france état d
esprit français est pourriez-vous nous
en a compté comme ça pourquoi
ah oui il ya eu ici si typiquement c'est
dans un avion il ya un français un
anglais un allemand et un japonais
et alors je suis pas si c'est un bon
exemple c'est un peu les japonais il ya
un peu grotesque et ridicule c'est le
japonais qui est ridicule quand même je
n'aime pas parce qu'on est à notre coach
gilles raillard d'ailleurs déjà courir
les prêts français s'est il faut il faut
des carottes alors des carottes
attendait tu vas détenons carottes avec
voulez pas vous poussez vous le dois
avoir des carottes le dessus je peux
faire ça vous vous levez voilages et des
carottes la tournée vous regardez ici on
va surfer s'est fait cuire pas cher ces
économies d'énergie voilà si vous jouez
à coup presque dix points
voilà c'est un truc très drôle on les
voit là on les voit bien on le voit
bella il faut 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 oui 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 dans l'art il faut neuf voilà
tient la barre tous les points
a viré sa nav 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
bon vous prendre 9 carottes ça c'est
l'humour français c'est bon comment on
fait pour faire cuire des carottes quand
on n'a pas de four de glace ça prend 9
carottes et puis pas arrêté de gigoter
sava comprend neuf carottes
alors on va les faire cuire sans rien
les carottes sont 9 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
noeuds si j'enlève une carotte paris si
j'enlève une carotte 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
les carottes sont cuites rien compris
qu'au tchad avant il y avait 9 à jean
lève une carte sont que 8 à d'accord des
comores dont la fuite
pas vraiment c'est comme si c'était cuit
quoi est-ce que vous avez l'autre chose
la plus drôle que samedi n'ont pas posé
la déclaration aimez vous faire au
peuple japonais kibo
logan au peuple japonais bien je dis au
peuple japonais que on peut écouter sur
radio monte carlo tous les samedis tous
les dimanches et sur fr3 partir de
février avec jean michel ribes le
dimanche de 20h à 20h45 je crois
également peut dire jouer peuple
japonais que j'ai écrit deux livres qui
sont en vente au seuil et l'autre
éditions atelier 86 je pense que c'est
vachement intéressant ça c'est un vrai
message publicitaire
on peut écouter mon âme bruit et bien
sûr et puis je vive le japon vivent
le général de gaulle vive la france vive
l'amitié cauchoise vivent aussi pierre
desproges et vivent surtout le cheikh
kocik et finalement pris très bien ça de
s'être fait piéger à son tour après ils
ont arrosé sa au sac et tous les deux
avec toute l'équipe
si bien que la fin de l'émission n'est
pas mon train etonnant non
[Musique]